[Music]
a couple that sweats together good stays
together let me talk to you
check out Selena Gomez and Justin Bieber
working on their Pilates bodies the
couple was snapped exiting hot Pilates
in West Hollywood on Wednesday a heated
fitness studio where temps go as high as
98 degrees the 25 year old bad liar
singer rocked blue puma leggings and a
white sweatshirt while 23 year-old
Bieber opted for a tank top and baggy
shorts I'm having a good time
it was so much fun a source told et in
December that Jelena is stronger than
ever
after rekindling their romance in
October they've been spotted riding
bikes attending church checking out
hockey games and now they're even taking
Pilates together ET spoke with Gomez in
November she opened up about how
fulfilled she feels right now I like to
choose to live my life in a way where I
want to be wait free and I know that's
impossible to do because I have a
million on me right now but I and
everybody does but I think it is
important to kind of go through your
life the way you want and I like to come
at things with my best that's all I know
how to do is just give my best
[Music]
you